completing not guilty in court earlier
this morning yeah this is a case we've
been following closely which involves
allegations of long-time sexual abuse
how do you plead to the
19 charges contained in that indictment
guilty or not this is the first time
Dances with Wolves actor Nathan chasing
horses appearing in Clark County
District Court after being indicted by a
grand jury who heard from two alleged
victims one of them saying long-term
sexual abuse began when she was underage
the other saying he sexually assaulted
her as an adult he has no guilt he has
no Guilford No Remorse no feelings
whatsoever representatives from the Las
Vegas Indian Center in the courtroom to
show support for alleged victims while
chasing horse supporters are here as
well the 46 year old is accused of
heading a cult known as the circle
claiming he's a medicine man and abusing
indigenous women and children throughout
the United States and Canada people that
I've known for years
were just you know um
poking their hooking themselves to this
guy like he was the Messiah Christopher
Boyd heads the Fort Peck Journal a
newspaper in Montana chasing horse was
banned from the Fort Peck reservation in
2015. the stories of him with underage
girls is
always been you know pretty well known
as like an Open Secret you know that uh
you know a lot of places you know you
can't figure out why he was never
brought any charges or brought to you
against him sooner in January chasing
horse was arrested at his North Las
Vegas home where he lived with several
wives do you think his time has come I
hope so chasing horse remains in custody
in downtown Las Vegas while Advocates
say they're offering support for any
other potential victims we will stand
we'll stay here and we'll fight
chasing horse also invoked his right to
a speedy trial so it's scheduled for
April that's soon especially for a
complex case like this one by the way
the Fort Peck reservation isn't the only
one chasing horse has been banned from
and he now faces federal charges along
with warrants in Montana and Canada as
more women come forward